فجر اليوم الاثنين اقيم حفل الاوسكار
بنسخته ال 95 الجوائز الاشهر في عالم
السينما حول العالم فيلم واحد اكتسح الحفل
وفاز بسبع جوائز من اصل 11 جائزه اترشح
لها بنتكلم عن فيلم
بجوائز افضل ممثله وافضل ممثل مساعد وافضل
ممثله مساعده وافضل مخرج وافضل سيناريو
اصلي ايضا وافضل مونتاج وختمها كمان بافضل
فيلم والفيلم بيحكي قصه مالكه مغسله
انهكتها المشاكل الاداريه مع سلطات
الضرائب فبتغوص في مجموعه عوالم موازيه
الفيلم بيجمع بين الحركه والكوميديا
والخيال العلمي وفوزه فتح نقاش كبير على
فكره تكون اغلبيه طاقم العمل من اصول
اسيويه وهذا الموضوع له رمزيه كبيره في
هوليود اللي من سنين متهمه بنقص التنوع
وبدات مؤخرا تحاول تغير هذا الموضوع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ما افضل ممثل فكانت مثل ما جاءت معظم
التوقعات
واللي بيحكي قصه مدرس بديل بينعزل في منزل
وبيعاني الحزن فريجر سجل في هذا الفيلم
عوده قويه بعد سنوات من الغياب وفاز بمعظم
الجوائز الكبرى السينمائيا في العالم هذا
السنه وعاده بيكون في كثير لحظات مؤثره في
حفل الاوسكار بس كانه السنه كانت الجرعه
اضافيه خلينا نتوقف مع ابرزها خاصه طبعا
للفائزين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في نقطه ثانيه على فكره مؤثره جدا استوقفت
كمان كثيرين فلحظه تلقي فيلم
للجائزه الصعود الطاقم للمسرح كان النجم
حارس هو اللي بيعلن الفائز وسلم وبارك
لطاقم الفيلم ومن ضمنهم الممثل كيهوكوان
اللي فاز عن الفيلم بجائزه افضل ممثل
مساعد ايضا ولحظه ما طلع على المسرح وسلم
على حارس كثار من الناس تذكرت فورا انه
اول ظهور له كان في فيلم انديانا جونز
اندومي عام
1984 يعني من اربعين سنه وظهوره كان كطفل
وكان وقتها امام هاريسون وبما اننا بنتكلم
عن لقطات مميزه فخلينا كمان نحكي عن
لقطتين ثانيين لفتوا الانظار اولهم رده
فعل الممثله انجيلا كانت مرشحه لجائزه
افضل ممثله مساعده وخسرت الجائزه وخلينا
نقول انه رده فعلها ما كانت فيها روح
رياضيه ابدا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللي لافت كمان هذه المره كان تصريحات
سياسيه تبعت الحفل فافضل فيلم وثائقي كان
من نصيب الفيلم اللي بيتناول قصه المعارض
الروسي اللي تسمم بغاز اعصاب في سيبيريا
في 2020 وتعالج في المانيا المتحدث باسم
الكرملين صرح وقال ما راح اتكلم عن جوانب
فنيه لاني ما شفت الفيلم بس الاكيد انه في
تسييس في الموضوع بيقصد طبعا انه يعني
امريكا فوزت الفيلم لانه بيحكي عن معارض
روسي
صغيره
ومديره قسم الافلام بجامعه اس اي اي دبي
اهلا فيكي معانا يا رزان اول شيء انا
عارفه انك انت من المؤيدين للفيلم اللي
اكتسح كل شيء
وبيقولوا انه كانوا بيخرجوا من السينمات
ما كانوا بيكملوه حتى
ايش تحسي
اولا كل اوسكار وانتم بخير وانت بخير يا
رب ان شاء الله
[ضحك]
الفيلم هذا طبعا فيلم خيال علمي فيلم
فانتازيا وطبعا يعني سمعنا حتى انه افلام
الجونرا اللي طول عمرها بتشتغل فيها افلام
الرعب هاي الافلام اللي هي مش دراما مش
افلام واقعيه افلام فيها خيال عالي وبمرات
بتكون صدمه للمشاهد الطبيعي لانه بحس احنا
متعودين على الشيء اللي متعودين عليه اللي
بنعرفه ايش يعني المشاهد الطبيعي يا رزان
يعني المشاهد اللي متعود يعني مش مثلا مش
المحبين افلام الجاره او متابعين الخيال
العلمي وبنفس الوقت مش مش مثلا اللي
بيحضروا افلامهم يكونوا انهم دخل في صناعه
الافلام لانه احنا فينا تفهم يعني مختلف
او منظور مختلف للافلام اللي معموله
بالجاره معين كل الافلام الواقعيه اللي
قريبه من عالمنا احنا طيب بس الان يعني
الاختلاف في الموضوع على الفيلم هذا الناس
جالسه بتقول انه يعني صراحه انه الفيلم تم
تفويزه بكثير من الجوائز لانه معظم طاقم
العمل من اصول اسيويه وانه هذا الشيء اللي
بتحاول الاسكر وهولي تثبت انه ما في
عنصريه وفي يعني خلينا نقول تشمل الكل
يعني
هذا الكلام ما بينطبق اذا بنعرف بنفهم كيف
المصوتين تبعون الاوسكارز اصلا بصوته
والجوائز هاي بتيجي من وين ممكن نحكي هذا
الكلام للترشيحات لانه الترشيحات تيجي من
الاكاديمي نفسها انه هم برشحوا بحاولوا
يعملوا انتلوجن بحاولوا يخلوا في ناس من
طبقات او من جهات ما كانش الها مكان زمان
وما كانت تترشح كفايه ولكن لما يجي للفوز
في كتير امور وعوامل الها خاص بالنقبات
تبعت الفنانين يعني جوائز الاخراج جوائز
الانتاج جوائز التصوير اللي بصوت عليها هم
ناس اللي في النقابه المخرجين ونقابه
المنتجين فيعني الموضوع بيجي له دخل
بالتكنيه والتكنيك تبع الاخراج او التصوير
او الانتاج اكثر من ما هو جهات سياسيه او
جهات مسؤوله الناس اللي بتصوت هي الناس
بتشتغل في صناعه الافلام بيكون لها علاقه
بالتكنيكال يعني قديش هذا الشيء احيانا
بنحس كمان يعني حرجعلك على نقطه الموضوع
السياسي لانه برضه حابب اتكلم معاك عليها
او تسييس الامور لكن الناس بتحس انه يعني
احيانا كثيره اذا الفيلم منفهم انه هذا حق
الاوسكار هذا حق مهرجانات يعني كانه صايره
الافلام اللي تنفهم سبه يعني او انه
للطبقه العاديه يعني مو المثقفه
بالعكس فيلم زي هذا مش لا يعتبر انه لا
طبقه مثقفه او لا بالعكس هو من نوع
الافلام اللي عاده تتهمش افلام هذا اول
فيلم خيال علمي بياخد احسن جائزه اوسكار
اخر فيلم يعني يعتبر مش واقعي اخذ جائزه
احسن اوسكار كان يعني
الافلام عاده بالعكس ما بتحسي انه الجهات
المثقفه بتنظر لها انها للترفيه ولكن لما
الخيال العلمي او الفانتازي يتخذ بطريقه
وينعمل له يعني ابعاد اكثر من فقط الترفيه
ممكن يضرب على عصب الرسائل اللي فيها
بطريقه كتير حلوه وجميله وهذا الفيلم انجز
هذا الشيء بطريقه رهيبه انه قدر يكون فني
وقدر يكون تقني بطريقه جميله وبنفس الوقت
يكون مضحك يعني هو كوميدي حتى يعني وهذا
الشيء عاده ما بياخذ جوائز
طيب نحنا كمان شفنا انه دخول يعني
الكرملين على الخط وبيقولوا انه في تسييس
لانكم اخترتوا الفيلم اللي عن المعارض
الروسي قديش فعلا يعني اصلا دائما يعني في
اتهامات لهولود والاوسكر بالتسيس يعني
لانه حتى الفنانين لما بيطلعوا احيانا
كثير بيقولوا خطابات مسيسه
شوفي هلا بالنسبه للجوائز زي مثلا جوائز
الافلام الوثائقيه الفن يقلد الحياه
والحياه تقلد الفن يعني انت لما تعملي
فيلم وثائقي راح تطرحي مواضيع حاليا هي
الها دخل بالسياسه والها دخل بالحوار
الاجتماعي اللي عم بصير بهذيك اللحظه فاي
شيء طبيعي انه هاي الافلام يكون الها
تعليق معين على وضع سياسي او على دول او
على اشياء احنا بنعيش عمالنا في الايام
اليوميه او نشوفها بالاخبار لانه فيلم
وثائقي في هذا الشيء بيجي يعني طبيعي
ناتشر معها يعني فلا ما بحس انه هي فازت
بهذا السبب بس انت لما تعطي جوائز لافلام
وثائقيه عدد الافلام وثيقيه رح تتطرق لهذه
المواضيع بطريقه طبيعيه
نقول هذا السنه كانت سنه مش طبيعي ما شاء
الله
احنا كتير مبسوطين بالذات الناس اللي من
جيلي اللي احنا كنا بالتسعينات كنا نحضر
له
مامي يعني وهو كمان انسان يتهمشوا له قصه
حزينه يعني كيف تتهمش في عالم السينما
بطريقه كتير
فالعوده تاعته هاي ورجعته اشي كتير جميل
للناس اللي بعمري اللي كانوا يحبوه لو
اختفى فجاه وهلا لقيناها يعني
قويه والفيلم حلو كثير وتمثيله بالفيلم
اصلا هو اقوى شيء بفيلم دوالي يعني طبعا
هم اخراج بس مش من اقوى افلام
لمرحله كتير عاليه باداؤه رهيب والحقيقه
كل احد بيتكلم عن اداءه يعني وحصد كثير من
الجوائز احنا بنشكرك على هذه النظره
السريعه كانت معنا رزان طقش مراجعه
تلفزيونيه وسينمائيه ومديره قسم الافلام
بجامعه دبي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]